étranger
International est
le pire être humain avec lequel j'ai jamais été en contact
et s'il vous plaît étranger,
la configuration est superbe je suis sûr que nous
allons avoir une grande compétition, ce
sont
des statistiques
étranger
je peux toujours garder ton cul
maintenant j'aime vraiment la
côte méditerranéenne de la France euh  avec la
direction du vent que nous avons aujourd'hui, c'est un
peu difficile,
euh, ce n'est peut-être pas le meilleur endroit où nous
pourrions être, mais d'après ce que j'ai vu du
capitaine Dag, c'est un endroit vraiment sympa, un
endroit génial, c'est très difficile, il faut juste
essayer de s'en assurer.  tu prends le
cerf-volant de la bonne taille et tu essaies juste de faire quelques
sauts parce que c'est très difficile dans
ces conditions
ouais
donc ouais heureux d'être ici ensoleillé et nous
avons du vent Malheureusement aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas dans la bonne direction donc il y a des rafales
mais c'est un jeu que nous  jouez toujours avec
des victoires alors espérez juste pour les jours à venir
et ça va être amusant et bien
merci étranger étranger
merci
et puis ça va dire 13. ça va
dire 12 minutes
cet endroit hier était vraiment bien
quand nous sommes arrivés pour la première fois  c'était un
vent droit de terre, ce qui est généralement
une direction de vent préférable et euh, les
prévisions se sont réalisées. Je suppose que lorsque le vent s'est
déplacé vers le large, il y a comme un gros
point avec des bâtiments qui dépassent, donc ça
rend le vent un peu en rafales mais euh, ça
fait pour  quelques gros sauts et c'est encore
un peu excitant ce ne sont pas les
conditions les plus confortables dans lesquelles j'ai été
je ne fais pas mes mouvements les plus
confiants mais j'en tire le
meilleur parti et je suis en France  il fait beau dehors il
y a des filles sur la plage les
conditions sont vraiment difficiles
euh c'est difficile de
tout faire c'est difficile de réussir tous
ses mouvements dans la chaleur donc
c'est juste une sorte de chance du tirage au sort si
vous obtenez si vous avez une bonne idée de vous  fais
un bon saut pour que
tout soit supérieur à 10.
chaque saut sera jugé sur
10. eh bien, c'était bien
pour moi si ce n'est pas
prendre le meilleur ici aussi
dans la série de
classement des camarades de classe
étrangers dans lesquels
j'ai commencé le kitesurf  Nouvelle-Zélande, mes
amis étaient des véliplanchistes. Je faisais
beaucoup de snowboard, alors je viens de m'acheter un cerf-volant
et j'ai appris à le piloter. Ce n'est
certainement pas la façon dont je
recommanderais. En fait, maintenant j'ai un
centre de kitesurf à Cabarete, le
Laurel Eastman Kite Center.  et c'est bien
mieux de venir apprendre s'entraîner avec des gens
qui savent bien ce qu'ils font la
première fois que je traînais mon corps dans l'
eau je portais mon bas de bikini
et je volais vraiment et je me suis retrouvé
avec un bikini qui glissait de haut en bas  et en
bas et tous les petits enfants sur la
plage se moquaient de moi mais j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance de ne pas m'être blessé, rien de grave ne s'est
produit
merci
l'évolution du kitesurf a été
si rapide que les gars deviennent vraiment
très bons à chaque concours, il y a du nouveau
tricks nouveaux styles c'est vraiment une
période excitante pour s'impliquer dans le
sport et aider dans son
évolution merci merci merci
étranger étranger étranger
ER
Je roule en Israël né en Californie
euh j'ai commencé le kitesurf il y a environ trois
ans et demi  J'ai
vu un film de Robbie Nash comme
enseigner le kitesurf et je
voulais juste l'essayer et je me suis lancé et
depuis, ça a été bien
euh c'était plutôt bien tu sais, je veux dire,
c'est vraiment bien, les meilleurs riders du
monde sont ici et  le niveau est assez
proche, tout le monde a le même niveau avec
juste de petits changements et
c'est juste que nous verrons qui est le meilleur
rider de tous, ça change tout le
temps et euh les gens s'améliorent
chaque jour et chaque jour il y a un nouveau
trick et  c'est vraiment difficile de suivre tu
sais
tu ne sais jamais qui sera le
meilleur demain ouais
étranger merci étranger c'est
Internet et
ah Tarifa
um
étranger
Je ne veux pas vraiment te retenir
allez
merci étranger
étranger
euh je me souviens de toi  60 euros slide pour hommes
merci
étranger
ouais le
personnage
rit
étranger
ok
fantastique sauf la victoire on n'a pas
d'étranger
cette année et l'année prochaine encore et l'
année prochaine encore
cartonner la Coupe du monde ici à Istanbul
on aime le sport on aime l'
organisation euh et c'est  très bien pour
Istanbul pour la Turquie pour le sport
et tout et vous créez une autre
organisation ouais nous formons une vieille
organisation euh en tant que groupe sportpes, nous
organisons toutes sortes d'événements sportifs mais
moi et mes partenaires venant de nous avons fait du surf sur le
snowboard qui
ce sont des choses extrêmes, c'est pourquoi nous aimons ce
genre de sport.
c'est par Internet ou dans
des magazines et qu'est-ce que tu sais, tu sais,
prends une leçon d'abord, tu sais,
passe trois à cinq heures
avec un instructeur et tu sais qu'après
ce temps, tu devrais être assez
confiant et compétent pour commencer le
kitesurf, tu sais  en quelque sorte tout seul,
tous les cerfs-volants d'aujourd'hui sont très bons,
vous savez, il y a eu beaucoup
d'améliorations au cours des deux dernières années. Les
cerfs-volants sont très stables, ils ne semblent pas
vouloir tomber du ciel comme ils le
disaient trois fois.  il y a des années et nous
avons également un système de dégagement rapide de sécurité sur nos
barres de direction. Si vous vous trouvez
dans une situation où vous vous sentez
menacé, vous pouvez simplement tirer un simple
petit levier sur votre barre et votre cerf-volant
est désactivé ouais, eh bien, le bon sens l'
a.  pour commencer à jouer avec le sport dont
vous avez besoin, vous connaissez au moins 50 mètres
de plage pour lancer votre cerf-volant et atterrir
votre cerf-volant et avoir un peu d'espace pour
traîner, jouer et vous
familiariser avec votre équipement, c'est notre
harnais qui  fait le tour de notre corps, ce
type particulier de harnais est un
harnais de siège qui entoure vos fesses, il
existe d'autres types de harnais qui font le
tour de votre taille, mais je préférerais utiliser
un siège car il ne remonte pas dans
votre poitrine, il reste agréable  et bas au
centre
de votre corps,
donc en gros, vous vous glissez dans votre harnais,
votre harnais est conçu
pour que votre corps supporte le poids du
cerf-volant et pas seulement vos bras, ce serait un
travail très difficile si vous n'aviez pas de harnais et
vous comptez simplement sur vos bras
et ce que nous avons ici est ce que nous appelons une
barre d'écartement à
laquelle vous êtes accroché
à votre barre,
d'accord,
c'est très facile, assez simple à entrer
et à sortir, vous pouvez serrer et ajuster en fonction de
vos besoins.  tu veux voler
donc c'est une question de confort avec le kite
surf tu sais il y a tu ne veux pas
être sur l'eau pendant deux heures et oh
ça fait mal et tu veux être très
à l'aise donc il y a toute une gamme de
harnais sur le marché donc je  Je pense que c'est ce
avec quoi vous vous sentez à l'aise,
c'est une planche bidirectionnelle, ce qui signifie que
vous
n'avez pas de queue ni d'avant de la planche, elle est
toutes deux symétriques, donc
en gros, vous êtes fixé dans une position
dans vos sangles de pied et vous pouvez suivre cette
voie.  vers la gauche et vous pouvez également aller dans cette
direction vers la droite en gardant votre talon
sur l'eau, ce qui rend le kite surf plus facile et
plus confortable. Nous
avons également des accessoires comme une poignée juste pour vous
aider à transporter sur la plage et aussi
pour les tricks de nos jours.  peut faire des spins et
toutes sortes de choses
et nous utilisons beaucoup de carres comme la
planche Edge en kitesurf donc nous avons besoin de
très peu de palmes et c'est tout à fait
suffisant pour faire le travail que nous devons
faire, je suppose que pour commencer le kitesurf, vous en avez
absolument besoin  une leçon, il y a beaucoup d'
instructeurs professionnels et
ils peuvent vous aider uniquement avec les bases
et une fois que vous avez les bases, vous pouvez
sortir et vous entraîner principalement avec le cerf-volant
d'abord, puis passer à la planche, mais
les leçons vous feront économiser beaucoup d'argent.  le temps
et nous garderons la sécurité à l'esprit donc
définitivement une leçon
les rêves
étrangers,
bien
entre ce [ __ ] de monde
ensemble
étranger
ce que je sais, je ne me suis pas très bien passé
dans la chaleur mais bon j'espère que ça ira
ouais pourquoi  pourquoi ça ne s'est pas bien passé, je ne
sais pas le premier, le cerf-volant était trop
petit après, il était trop grand et
mais je ne pouvais tout simplement pas faire ce que j'ai
l'habitude de faire aujourd'hui, je veux dire, nous avons de très bonnes
conditions  euh le soleil est dehors l'eau est
chaude il y a de grandes vagues c'est juste
génial et une participation fantastique regarde
tous ces gens
merci
étranger
je ne pense pas
faire une deuxième place aujourd'hui
il est très content je suis très content
étranger
exactement euh ouais je  j'ai 14 ans j'ai commencé quand j'avais
10 ans j'ai appris en cabareti ouais
étranger
pour un concours ouais et on espère
te voir dans un meilleur endroit car
hier c'était trop court hein ouais ouais
hier j'ai fait un très mauvais coup
sous-alimenté mon mec était trop petit  et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui je peux réparer ce train
d'hier et comme si je terminais ma
très bonne décision,
c'est
celle-ci, deux séries, trois coups Floyd
wow ouais c'est un travail dur c'est comme
hier j'ai fait un très mauvais travail et aujourd'hui
j'en ai besoin  pour réparer mon désastre d'
hier
et j'ai gagné environ cinq coups et mes six
six coups j'ai perdu contre environ parce que
ouais tellement fatigué je m'écrase tout le temps je
n'ai pas l'air très très bien et ouais c'est
la vie
étrangère
si tu t'entraînes cinq  ans en
Californie, tu peux être très bon même si
tu es si jeune ouais ouais parce que
euh ce
n'est pas un problème de poids tu sais,
ok, créer des liens si tu peux être jeune et euh
et pas la télé et tu peux en gagner même
parce que tu as des différences
euh  tricks tu as du mouvement ouais
je me sens fantastique à propos de toute l'
organisation tu penses que tu penses que maman est
avec nous
les meilleurs moments de ma vie
ok alors Fabiana tu as gagné la
séance féminine le freestyle à six ans
rouleau d'assaisonnement c'était ok pas trop fatigué
non c'est
tu as passé un bon moment, un très bon moment sur
l'eau, le vent était vraiment bon,
vraiment bon Brenda et non ouais, c'était
vraiment un bon moment, je pense que nous nous amusons dans
l'eau Aaron, alors tu as gagné ce euh
secondaire World Tour, comment te sens-tu
bien  c'était vraiment de bonnes conditions
euh rien d'autre j'ai eu des œufs à temps
ouais et c'est les nouveaux tricks on
le savait et tout le monde était oh et tu l'appelles
euh je ne sais pas tout le monde l'appelle l'
hélicoptère et l'hélicoptère, d'accord et
tu l'as fait deux fois  et je sais que tu
as de nouveaux tricks à venir ouais j'ai
moins plus de tricks
étrangers
quelqu'un doit m'apprendre à faire du kite et de
la planche tu sais j'ai vu des seniors de
mon âge ici je pense qu'il y a aussi des membres de
l'équipe merci beaucoup
amusez-vous
bien étranger toc
toc
je vais être
là
et bien il y a beaucoup de coureurs d'Afrique du Sud
qui sont plutôt très
très bons nous avons les meilleurs français ici nous
avons le premier portugais le champion
juste un nouveau champion du Portugal donc  nous
pourrions avoir un événement très excitant ici sur
la plage de Durban. J'espère
bien faire mais il y a beaucoup de bons gars du
Cap et évidemment des
gars internationaux donc nous devrons voir que
ça va être vraiment bien, c'est sympa
vent belles vagues
bons concurrents donc je pense que ça va
être très agréable non non non je
pense que le climat joue un grand rôle l'
environnement chaleureux et convivial ce
lieu merveilleux ici au Suncoast Casino
et vraiment si vous le regardez, c'est une
fenêtre sur l'Afrique du Sud
euh, cela démontre que l'Afrique du Sud est
un endroit chaleureux et convivial et nous aimons
que le reste du monde le voie et
vienne visiter nos côtes et ce
merveilleux pays qui est le nôtre
par la présentation ici
ensemble très très gentiment, nous sommes
fiers de pouvoir  pour mettre cela ensemble
pour le monde du carton aussi,
je suis tombé plusieurs fois,
je pense que oui, j'ai essayé de rester debout,
mais euh, j'allais, euh, quand je sautais,
je ne pouvais pas rester assez au vent
pour un côté, des
amis
à côté
de  moi,
nous attendons avec impatience un grand spectacle,
le kitesurf se prête vraiment à la
marque Vodacom et nous sommes très heureux du
sport que nous soutenons presque probablement
à l'avenir,
merci
aujourd'hui, c'est une direction fantastique pour la
victoire et les riders sont prêts  c'est une bonne
journée pour concourir et j'espère qu'ils
apprécieront
je crierai un jour au
football
étranger
mais je ne suis pas arrivé au bout et je n'ai pas
vraiment fait de passe de poignée
euh en fait j'en ai réussi une juste
après mais après qu'il ait fini mais
J'ai fait quelques boucles de cartes et ouais, ça s'est
déchaîné à l'
étranger
plutôt bien ouais j'ai un bon pressentiment
sur ce concours donc ça va être
bien merci c'est un
travail difficile il faut imaginer
ce que la caméra voit donc c'est pour ça
qu'on toujours  positionnez la caméra derrière
le pilote pour que ce qu'il regarde soit
le même que ce que regarde la caméra,
vous devez donc essayer d'imaginer la
meilleure prise de vue pour la caméra, il est donc très
important de vous mettre en position pour
obtenir  un bon euh un bon coup
oh
je suis vraiment content de mes résultats je me
suis beaucoup entraîné ces derniers temps tout au long de l'
hiver je me suis entraîné dur
pour cet événement et je suis venu ici juste vous
savez dans l'espoir d'acquérir une
expérience internationale  et vous ne savez pas, je m'attends à un
but, mais le gagner est tout simplement génial, c'est
je suis vraiment heureux de le gagner oui pour
la première fois
à Durban et j'ai passé un moment fantastique,
ça a été génial
merci
étranger merci
modèles
étrangers
du tout
oups
merci
c'est
qui est venu
merci
tout le monde
étranger
bonjour ça
rentre ici euh euh
organisations
Junior
tu vois étranger
Peppa
étranger merci
ouais ouais
merci étranger merci
étranger
c'est ma première fois ça a été une super
semaine même si on n'a pas eu beaucoup de
vent ça fait  a ça a été un moment vraiment agréable
les dernières vacances,
nous avons fait du bon surf sur les récifs extérieurs
Je n'ai jamais
vraiment eu de
gentillesse étrangère dans les parages
ouais
étranger étranger
étranger
merci
cher
un peu difficile mais euh c'est super
amusant
donne-moi beaucoup de temps
étranger
amis étrangers
différence
merci étranger
étranger
c'est le double
de la musique
terrible
étranger
c'est un rêve pour moi c'est un vrai rêve alors
merci étranger
je ne sais pas
étranger
pourquoi est-il plus gentil
bébé